what is up kids it is Jerry it's me I'm
on the road it's a nice overcast day
outside which is cool get away from
summertime heat and I got a little bit
of a first impressions video for you who
I know it's a little bit late and I'm
sorry but I got one so yesterday morning
I saw x-men days of future past this
movie is obviously very highly
anticipated Bryan Singer returning
picking up where he sort of left off you
know after x2 and yeah this is you know
a big event of a movie they're uniting
the timelines so to speak bring in the
cast's together and how does it fare
well let's talk about it um this movie
at least as an AO is pretty incredible I
i really i really enjoyed this i thought
they did a fantastic job I mean first
and foremost I gotta say the cast is
great I really love the cast in this
movie I like that this x-men film truly
does feel like an ensemble you know
you've got all kinds of people from the
original x-men movies and from x-men
first class you've got Patrick Stewart
you've got Ian McKellen you have Michael
Fassbender you have james mcavoy who I
mean ever like I said everyone's good in
this movie I loved James McAvoy in this
I mean it's a comic book you know
superhero movie so there's a lot of
stuff happening there's a lot going on
but I think this movie does do a good
job of really allowing its characters to
live and breathe and you know a lot of
this stuff is tied into them because you
know a big part of it has to do with
getting young professor xavier to
believe and hope again you know which is
a very human and a very you know
emotional psychological struggle and his
performance especially at least for me
you know was very affecting I mean just
in the little details he had me misty
eyed a few times and I just thought he
was great Jennifer Lawrence back she
does a good job Hugh Jackman obviously
is great because he is Wolverine Peter
Dinklage is really good Evan Peters is
Quicksilver he's only in it for a little
bit but his scene is pretty badass and i
gotta say uh nicholas hoult is beast i
really appreciated that they went
practical effects for most of that
because i know that it seems like based
as a character will I keep switching up
the approach to the design of the
execution so it was
practical and there are a lot of really
cool you know cameos and end people who
pop up in this um so yeah I don't want
to give too much away but i really liked
what they did with the story on this
whole you know time travel and you know
changing the past to affect the future
and the sort of picking up in the wake
of x-men 3 I thought it was really well
directed really well shot well paced it
moves along pretty fast but there's
still a lot of you know good character
stuff to chew on and that's something
that I find neat about you know as much
as people can play in it and even as
much as I've complained about you know
Sony and Fox not wanting to play nice
with Marvel I do think it's kind of neat
though that you have these different
universes that shine for different
reasons you know sony has a specific
flavor they get with spider-man marvel
has a certain flavor they get with the
Avengers movies and I think Fox has a
certain flavor that they get with these
x-men films and I think that's cool to
see so yeah i I just I really like this
movie I might go check it out again I
saw it in 3d I don't know I wasn't super
psyched about the 3d but the action is
really good really really creative you
know yo fights and in and showcases of
these characters powers and it always
feels appropriate which I much
appreciate it you know this movie is has
a good balance I think between you know
character stuff and you know
social scenes and action you know it's
not a it's not a big loud action movie
as much as it is you know and ensemble
piece you know with certainly with
sci-fi elements in action and and stuff
but i think they strike a really nice
balance between those other they really
managed what they set out to do and it's
cool because you get you know a dose of
the future and then you also get that
you know retro vibe that was so cool to
see in x-men first class so there's a
lot to be enjoyed about this movie
that's just the designs and the
different superheroes so this movie kind
of has a little bit everything to use
the cliche you know it's got good action
it's got some really good character
stuff it's got an interesting story and
it's you know very primal and related to
the essential struggles of humanity and
stuff like that so yeah I'm feeling very
strong on this so let's talk about it
what's your what's your favorite x-men
movie to date and maybe who's your
favorite character let's talk cuz I'm no
expert but yeah until next time I'm
about to go shoot with Ryan so x-men
days of future past is the movie I am
Jerry choose
you